thank you
[Music]
the people who think that Jeffrey
Epstein killed himself are about to look
like
don't talk about me like that right
sitting right here you mean that he
really didn't I thought that was just a
conspiracy theory oh what is it what is
it no there's a there's a great there's
a new report out about that sheds light
on what actually happened
through the disgraced financier during
his final moments and what came after so
don't say the federal the Federal Bureau
of Prisons released this information
under the Freedom of Information Act and
they include a detailed psychological
reconstruction of the events that
happened before his suicide
and it also helps to quell the belief by
many people that he uh conspiracy
theories that he uh killed himself so
check this out
so you guys know that he got to the
facility right apparently he was he was
staying in in jail and the Bureau of
Prisons had to move him because of all
the media attention right and he was
complaining about a running toilet he
said that the toilet is running all
night it was very annoying so loud very
loud you're in jail [__] yeah
you can make complaints
cruel and unusual the hotel and [__]
he was also upset wake up call tomorrow
look at new sheets please no he wanted a
new uniform because he was upset that
when his his um lawyers come to visit
him slimming enough no the color he
didn't like the color it's all orange
and he wanted a brown jumpsuit this
[__] act like he got options he was
requesting these things he's like it
just really wide right here and he knows
the secret menu in jail
he also got screened right so they
screened him
um and they determined that he said he
had more than 10 female sexual partners
within the previous five years
so that's that's it
okay and Records when he said it does it
say it doesn't say like this one said it
10.
he Winks at the guy he he also
um like so there are logs right that the
people who were watching him they say
that he was observed sitting on the edge
of the bed he was lost in thought he had
his head against the wall
um and
then
they also they also came out with
um you know what what happened that day
right so so Epstein's found with the bed
sheet strip around his neck and he's
deceased and the cameras yeah they
malfunctioned No cameras and the footage
was deleted but they didn't have a bunk
mate that was like this buff has bald
guy that was like I was sleeping no he
got moved so he wasn't there so he was
he was by himself he was by himself
completely by himself Oh I thought he
was in there with them he was but then
the bug me got moved out before this
transpire oh after he killed him but
they so during an internal memo that now
has Lee thinks the information Freedom
of Information Act now we can get the
truth so the the agency the Bureau of
Prison said that his death is blamed on
seriously reduced Staffing levels
improper lack of training and follow-up
and oversight and now they're like hey
these are the steps that we're taking to
fix these issues
right
I'm just glad that they finally have a
logical explanation of what happened
this is leaked information Nick this
wasn't going to come out they had they
were keeping this under close
wait what do you guys saying
they were keeping this I'm just glad we
finally have answers dude they were
keeping yeah
no no so they have the secrets out yeah
yeah yeah and yeah you know
understaffing was happening to the whole
country especially yeah
Tova Noel and Michael Thomas who were
guarding Epstein they fell asleep that
day that's correct they they fell asleep
both of them uh both of them yeah they
heard they have really nice houses now
yeah they well first they were real
would you be afraid to take that deal
though um would you be afraid
look they were shopping online for
furniture and motorcycles okay and then
yeah other we just got tired
literally what it says what because they
were they're great they're getting ready
check that does it really say that [__]
is he [__] around no no no no he's
not he's not looking around
they were shopping because they were
like I'm ready for my payday dude so
they're on Living Spaces in
Harley-Davidson dude they're playing
with each other
[Applause]
right and then um they walked around the
units common area
um uh they're supposed to be walking
around like doing Patrol right but they
didn't do it like right here here and
there right like here in when he killed
him that exact moment yeah and um
instead of making the rounds every 30
minutes for two hours they they appear
to have been asleep and they admitted to
falsifying log entries but avoided jail
time under a deal with Federal
prosecutors so they got Justice
[Laughter]
this one happened we found we got to the
bottom of this first of all I like how
long it took them to release this and
it's the most shittiest there's nothing
I'm just glad that what they're saying
is if we can get TSA in jail then one
the only person to know the secrets of
the most powerful people in the whole
world the next one we find if we ever
find another one we'll never fall from
our fingertips yeah you know who I blame
for this it was it well you know what I
blame for this
oh you're gonna blame white people
come on what were the guards were they
like
I just said a guy's name was like
what is that [__] polish
the guards I thought the guards were
like yeah Caribbean or Jamaican or hey
why you do that
hey are you gonna blame white people
really dude
[Laughter]
Michael Thomas what that's both of them
all right you know what Caribbean you
know what all right hey sometimes you
take a nail sometimes check it out I
spoke too soon
and motorcycles come on I should have
just trusted this [__] article
it's a great deal stereotype unlocked
Furniture bikes no they got homes they
got they got a payday too they did get a
Payday they got a race why do they get a
Payday they got fired
you get a Michael Kors sunglasses I know
right yeah
those were again
I mean goat my grandma left them to me
it's just not worried at all this [__]
yeah right yo you you see that [__]
coming back uh coming out again like
talking about the list is that well it's
been out right but then now like they're
tying Bill Gates to uh oh yeah the
bridge
underage and underage chick right yeah
yeah he likes to play bridge with and
then they would [__] play bridge bridge
dude Bridge is a game for old people so
it makes no sense is it like what is it
what is it what would you compare it to
is it like cards
it's like a card game you play across
like in twos and twos right yeah she's
played backgammon instead what the [__]
you want to play brick what that's like
that [__] string game dude I think I
think bridge is an aphrodisiac yeah
right yeah sets the tone yeah that's why
because you're good this is pretty
boring huh yeah yeah right
like after the whole Epstein thing
happened right all of these divorces
happened too Bill Gates and Melinda yeah
just split up why because she found out
that's what everyone maybe they didn't
want to be connected to the to be
distanced because they act like we dumb
yeah we kind of are though we're pretty
we got them all
yeah
watch you hear it first [__] you
know and you know who I blame okay
all right you got it you got it the
media of the media
the White media yeah which channel every
all of it corporate media because we
don't know who killed we don't know who
killed it yeah not in death why is there
no journalist that's covering the [__]
out of this story of the century dude
actually the biggest word of all time a
pedophile biggest story of all time yeah
involving top celebrities top [__]
Bankers top [__] politicians
yeah this is also from the references
dude another piece from the report that
helps to quell that there's any
conspiracy involved with Epstein and his
sex shopping ring so one of the people
he reached out to was
um that cat the um the [__] gym coach
Larry in the sour no way the guy who who
sexually assaulted all those 100 counts
yeah yeah
Epstein reaches out to him he was one of
the people he reached out to dude
while he was in jail
wait right here it's in the report what
did he say Larry Nazar bro he's he's
real [__] the Olympic pedophile yeah
he was the second biggest pedophile that
year first was [__] Jeffrey guess
what Simone biles said she said he was
protected and nobody felt like they
could [__] talk wow some Big's going
on out there but it's all conspiracy hey
what about that football coach which one
yo yeah you're gonna put the um the [__]
is his name he was touching the dudes on
the teams he's an NFL guy forever no uh
College yeah I can't remember his name
Al Pacino played him in that movie right
Sandusky Sandusky thing oh Sandusky wait
he's tied into this too nah but I mean
you know same type of [__] I mean we
might as well take him down while we get
them right hey what about Jared the
subway guy oh yeah yeah yeah
do they yeah they put them down because
he wasn't a part of
so they say
he was kicking it he was but he was
going out to do the like the the boys
[__] up and but no but Jared from Subway
he was doing something he's doing the
little boys
oh like the charity event actually I
don't know what I'm saying don't make me
look crazy
on charity events he went on tour it was
like yeah
I don't know if it was his girlfriend or
some lady but she was like she was like
egging the conversation on and like yeah
you like Sting operation yeah like you
like young like calling out like you're
like you're on the plug for him right
yeah yeah get him like a kid yeah wait
she was like miked up and [__] yeah
apparently apparently they're there she
was like an informant and she had like
terabyte he had terabytes of like child
porn yeah so he kind of did it to
himself he was kind of a little too loud
on the street it's deep Bro he got
egotistical with that Subway money he's
like man I'm [__] you're right in the
world he's like he's like first thing
I'm doing is buying Seagate hard drives
[Laughter]
[Music]